a company we follow quite closely HLF
Herbalife Herbalife verbally Herbalife
Herbalife I load the Herbalife story
because all of us have been talking
about it for 18 months now we're talking
about it for only one reason Bill Ackman
who's a very rich and very successful
man made a bet that's it
so I'm gonna tell you everything that
you need to know about it and when I'm
done you and I can stop thinking about
this forever Herbalife is a publicly
traded company it sells nutritional
supplements vitamins shakes things
that'll make you skinny GNC is a company
that does the same thing but there's an
important distinction
GNC has stores and sells through those
stores to people who want vitamin shakes
Herbalife sells to people called
distributors who then find their own
customers here's a way to understand the
difference this is GN C's quarterly
revenue there's a lot of variation it
goes up in the summer because people
want to lose weight in the summer
this is Herbalife's quarterly revenue
there's much less variation because
Herbalife's customers are not people who
want to lose weight they're people who
want to start a business so there are
two questions is this fair and is it
legal no it is not fair
Herbalife is a four point eight billion
dollar company when it sells through to
its distributors it forces them to take
on its risks the risks of holding real
estate if they want to put up a
storefront the risks of marketing the
risks of holding inventory now is it
legal
probably the Illinois Attorney General
has collected complaints from
distributors who say the Herbalife
misled them about the potential upside
and refused to take back unsold
inventory this year the Federal Trade
Commission announced that it was looking
into the same complaints but we're not
talking about this because people bought
Herbalife and lost money we're talking
about this because Bill Ackman a very
rich very successful man made a billion
dollar bet with his own money that
Herbalife will fail there's a story to
be told about the people who wanted to
start a business
bought Herbalife products and then
couldn't sell them there is no story to
be told about Bill Ackman
he's just a very rich very successful
man talking